Warriors? Cavs.
Cavs have tarantulas fighting for them.
I don't fight for the Cavs. I'm Kevin of Durant.
Small forward to the Oklahoma citadel well, okay. Technically. I'm a free agent
But I'm gonna re-sign for one more year because the gold cap goes up and I can get more money. It doesn't matter
That's not why I'm here
You could come fight for us
Excuse me. I was there when Steven Adams was flagrantly fouled by a shadow with your face
You kicked him in the bollocks!
I did.
In the name of House Thunder champions of the Northwest division,
Rightful Kings of the Western Conference; former Sonics of Seattle and the first men
I, Kevin of Durant, Former MVP,
Sentence you to justice.
Do you have any last words?
You're a  doodie
What'd you call me?
I said do your duty
Ow.